for the longest time i kind of just had
the childlike faith that uh you know in
the christian church they say have a
child like faith and i kind of just
believe because everybody else around me
believed because i was raised that way
where it started to become something
logical when i started to take steps
away from a child like faith the father
of quantum physics one of his famous
quotes is uh the first sip from the
glass of natural sciences will make you
an atheist but at the bottom of the
glass god is waiting for you they have
this circle civil knowledge of science
or whatever and and it makes them an
atheist you know but then you start to
you start to expand your knowledge you
start to go deeper and deeper and deeper
and you realize that the questions we
have about the universe are on a 10 time
scale so for every question that we
answer we have you know 10 to 100 more
and
that's where a lot of these scientists
who spend their lives trying to answer
the question of our universe
sort of at the end they realize that the
universe is kind of omniscient and it
makes its own opinions but they never
really will say hey that's a god so i
started take a step away from childlike
faith and i started to really understand
it and really try to understand what was
going on and see if i could press my
faith and bend it that the abrahamic god
is the real one and that there is one
true god and the more i started to bend
my faith and press it against what
science has said and what made sense the
more i realized that it actually stood
up you know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
i think there's another thing too it's
it's the perseverance aspect too like
we're more willing to stick through with
things that we set out with an intention
it's impossible to have empathy for
others if you're not patient so my love
bless you for that first of all i'm
going to agree with the fact that
the whole thing you said about friends
where it's like if they're affecting you
more than you're affecting them then you
should probably get some new friends
you want to be investing
stocks shares bonds you want to be
investing in crypto
because there's this thing called
inflation which means every year that
passes by
the value of a dollar goes lower and
lower and lower and the reason being is
because they're printing more money
right that's why money is haram at least
the paper money is haram provided that
you're actually there and you're being a
good father and the mother's being a
good mother best conditions and behind
the mic hamza andreas zorces we will go
in with our final three with brother
angel
it's not just a responsibility on you
it's responsibility on all the children
especially your father in our private
area is very elastic and yeah if you go
too fast the skin will literally crease
up into like the edge
of like the little clipper things and
you will literally clip your skin so you
don't want to be on youtube or the
internet or anything
that that amount of time but it's it's
the the fact is that's what we're doing
podcast in the dunya the three muslims
podcast today we're joined with another
very special guest
luke caverns how are you doing today bro
i'm doing very well thank you guys for
having me on i really really appreciate
it
yeah it's our it's our it's honestly our
honor and pleasure to have you on for
those who don't know uh luke caverns is
a christian brother with his own channel
and where can they find that channel
uh you can just find it on youtube just
look up luke caverns i've got uh it's
more of my personal channel i just kind
of talk about whatever's interesting to
me and then i've got a more formal
channel which was actually the
it was actually what i had in mind when
i started youtube it's called ancient
origins with luke caverns and it's
basically just from
from the beginning to the end of our
history and then once i kind of cover it
i'll go into more particular things but
it's basically just
i believe and a lot of other people
believe that our ancient past is pretty
cloudy and that we've been lied to about
a lot of things to protect people with
power and people that can manipulate
everybody in the world and so i kind of
just break that down and i try to do it
very neutrally i'm a christian
but
in my opinion i think that the evidence
lying within the world should point
towards a creator and so that's sort of
what i'm trying to do and that
if that makes sense yeah so that's
that's what my two channels about loot
caverns and then ancient origins with
luke caverns wow wow that's awesome
that's amazing bro that's amazing um
rami do you have any questions because i
have one on my mind
take it real go ahead all right
my first question bro luke
living amidst a whole big population of
of you know people our age our
demographic even older and younger
especially in the west where
the whole concept of theism believing in
a god it's almost like off-putting it's
almost like restricting our our
individuality at least the way they
market it today and you see atheism is
just rampant it is a belief to an extent
so this this whole belief of atheism it
is very very rampant today um what makes
you believe in god you say that
everything points to a creator so you
can you can let us know anything um not
let us know things you don't want to
talk about obviously but just go into
that bro what makes you believe in a
creator right
well um
for the longest time i kind of just had
the childlike faith that uh you know in
the christian church they say have a
child like faith and i kind of just
believe because everybody else around me
believed because i was raised that way
where it started to become something
logical when i started to take steps
away from a child like faith and i tried
to on my last video i talk about
how the father of quantum physics one of
his famous quotes is
the first sip from the glass of natural
sciences will make you an atheist but at
the bottom of the glass god is waiting
for you and it's these people who
they
they they have this circle civil
knowledge of science or whatever and and
it makes them an atheist you know but
then you start to you start to expand
your knowledge you start to go deeper
and deeper and deeper and you realize
that the questions we have about the
universe are on a ten time scale so for
every question that we answer we have
you know 10 to 100 more
and
that's where a lot of these scientists
who spend their lives trying to answer
the question of our universe sort of at
the end they realize that the universe
is kind of omniscient and it makes its
own opinions but they never really will
say hey that's a god so i started take a
step away from childlike faith and i
started to really understand it and
really try to understand what was going
on and see if i could press my faith and
bend it that the abrahamic god is the
real one and that there is one true god
and the more i started to bend my faith
and press it against what science has
said and what made sense the more i
realized that it actually stood up you
know
and um so that happened in about 2018 i
had just gotten into
2018 or 2017 i just gotten into
egyptology and i was listening to these
university podcasts on audible and one
of the first questions that the guy
asked and i don't remember why this ties
into egyptology but he talks about the
beginning of time and he talks about how
the universe can only be made one of two
ways and it's either it never had a
beginning which is possible but
unexplainable or logically the universe
was created by an uncreated creator and
so that was sort of where it started and
it's kind of evolved over time and i've
we could go down a bunch of different
rabbit holes but
what i i guess a little uh thought i
just came up with a few weeks ago is
that
the evidence that that the world should
contain enough evidence enough unbiased
evidence that it should point towards a
creator if that makes sense so that's
kind of
where i'm where i'm at right now
okay
if you don't mind me asking bro
why do you say what one one true god
because we as muslims we believe in one
true god we believe in allah one god we
don't believe that there's multiple gods
we don't believe that there's many gods
or you know that things or creation
should be things that are there to fight
and worshipped um but in a lot of
different religions polytheism is there
too so what makes you
believe in one true god because a lot of
christians from what i've discussed with
that we've seen they believe in the
trinity or they believe in multiple gods
okay
that's interesting so the trinity it's
kind of i i am a christian but i kind of
ignore the concept of the trinity
because it's either taken in so many
different ways i think that
you know
with yahweh who is just god um and the
holy spirit and jesus christ himself
um
it's kind of it's kind of messy when you
get to into explaining that and you know
they say it's the trinity but it's one
or is it three you know it just kind of
doesn't really make sense and in my head
i'm like well
i can't really explain that but as far
as
do
and then we could get into the whole
thing of the actual translation of uh
genesis in hebrew and how you know
sometimes it's talking about lord god
but then it says god and if you go if
you go deep into hebrew it's actually
plural so it says in the beginning the
gods created the heaven and the earth
but what it really means by those gods
is all of these ethereal beings like you
know the angels gabriel michael the
archangels you know they call they call
them gods so i don't dive too deep into
you know like the the messiness of oh
what do we really mean are there
multiple gods because as a human being
if i saw a legion of angels in the sky
i mean they're basically all gods but
one of them is the mastermind behind it
all and so it just makes sense to me
that there's one
mind behind all of this you know what i
mean and whatever you want to call
that's underneath him if you want to
call those gods i don't really get into
that um so i don't really have like a
really specific answer for you but i do
believe that there was one mind that set
everything in motion if that makes sense
even like when you look in greek
mythology like they have all these
demigods but then there's always that
one so a lot of different comparative
you know religions cultures followings
they always point towards one true god
and some of them mistranslate that and
take it out of context and try to say
okay yep there's still two but then okay
no there has to be one there can be two
yeah
i was actually um i was actually
watching game of thrones last night uh
with my girlfriend and um
and i was they were talking about all
these gods and game of thrones of course
it's obviously all fiction but i was
thinking about it and i was like you
know
it would only make sense that there
really is just one god like logically if
there is a god there's probably just one
because how would they how would it even
work out you know what i mean there's
there's one that's in control that just
based off of like common sense if there
is
yeah you know i'm really glad that you
mentioned that because um the reason he
he kind of called on my name a second
ago is because in our class we were
actually talking about the the the
logical argument for god um and
how at the end of it people were asking
well why can't there be multiple of
these you know gods that we basically
uh explained have to exist to explain
our existence in a nutshell basically
and we the answer basically is is very
straightforward it's essentially what
you said that it wouldn't work if there
were multiple ones in the sense that you
can't have more than one all-powerful
being because if they're all powerful
they must have the capability to
overtake the other or to take the other
out of existence or something like that
so you can't have too all-powerful you
can't have two necessary because if
they're both necessary then if you
remove one you still have one necessary
which means that the one you removed
wasn't necessary to begin with and so on
and so forth and allah he actually makes
this argument in the quran he says
had there been gods with allah
each of them would have tried to
outstrip the other and take his own
kingdom for himself
so it's essentially saying that it
wouldn't work out if there had been you
know multiple creators multiple gods and
in the sense that you just described so
i think that's that's a great point of
agreement there bro a lot of people also
think that okay what if i have two gods
that that both work in unison right they
both agree on everything and they're
both co-equal and co-partners and that's
how we have the the dunya or the world
around us and that doesn't make sense
because if they're both you know
necessary existences and they're both
both powerful the fact that they have to
even agree with each other for these set
premises in and of itself is a
limitation so then they're no longer all
powerful and no longer necessary anymore
yeah exactly
depending what that yeah exactly you
just take the problem and you push it a
step back
that they can they both always agree but
now they're
reliant and dependent on that agreement
so how would they be god at the end of
the day how would they be all powerful
you explained it very well inshallah so
um it's amazing luke because you you're
a christian right
i am
um are you a unitarian christian would
you ascribe to the nomination because
you seem to be i would say uh i don't
want to call you heretical but that's i
think how many christians would look at
your views
oh
yes yeah yeah yeah i
oh man i don't get scoffed at by anybody
more than i do uh other christians you
know for trying to talk to them about uh
what i believe in because
i try to explain to them i'm like i'm
like you guys you think you know god and
people on this earth they think they
understand god you don't like it you
don't it's he's so much bigger than
uh like an old man with a white beard
sitting on a cloud i mean he is the mind
that exists on this planet he exists on
the dark side of mars he exists outside
of our solar system he exists outside of
our universe you don't understand him
you know and so
yeah it's just
i have so many views that we could get
into and um and when you start to and
i'm sure it's this way with the quran as
well um you have to pick how you're
going to go about your faith because are
you going to just kind of believe the
bible's metaphorical because if you do
okay that makes sense like some of it's
metaphorical and in the old testament or
are you going to take it all literally
which a lot of christians take it a
hundred percent literally
and then if you do well then i can say
oh okay let's start pressing your faith
a little bit and you start asking real
you start asking particulars you know
you start asking about oh well how did
that how are adam and eve were they
really the only two people
on the earth at the time were they
really because just a couple of books
later it says that a brother and a
sister can't lay with each other because
it's an abomination but that's what he
intended for the children and it's also
biologically doesn't make sense you
can't populate the entire earth from two
specimens of any you know
and um and you start asking these
questions
and you start really getting into it and
a lot of christians don't like that um
and so that's kind of where i've been
over the last several years but i'd say
as far as uh
i'd say as far as where i am
religiously what i could categorize
myself is there's there's like uh
there's like you know orthodox i would
probably say i'm unorthodox which
doesn't really exist i i probably
wouldn't find anybody that would
actually agree with me on all my
religious views but i'm unorthodox is
what i would say how about this how
about this you're you're
you're a real monotheist or you believe
in one god
you i feel like
do you genuinely feel like
where you are in life
you fully belong in
in christianity or is it because you
were like born into it and you you kind
of feel like you you're very familiar
with it and that's why you you choose to
like okay cool i'm still christian
because it seems like if if what you're
saying it's like you don't really agree
with the mainstream beliefs of
christianity and and the whole trinity
and all that but you do believe in this
more orthodox but unorthodox way of just
monotheism where do you where do you
belong
yeah i don't think i i just don't belong
to anybody but the creator you know what
i mean like i don't
i just don't
agree with anybody um i mean about the
basic stuff i do you know um but i just
find very few people who agree with
anything that i'm talking about um yeah
i just don't feel like i belong in any
sort of box you know what i mean i don't
fit in a church if that makes sense yeah
so i want me to take over and we had
this brother um by the name of blogging
theology his name is paul williams and
he said that um he used to be christian
by the way before he was uh you know
he's muslim and
he saw that in in christianity um it's
mainly a religion about jesus
not the religion of jesus peace be upon
him and a lot of people don't understand
that when they hear that because they're
like what do you mean christianity is a
religion about jesus isn't it of jesus
but it's like everything that that rami
is going to go into um now hopefully he
goes into it's not really what it makes
it out to be
before
just sorry um
one thing
that i'll just admit
um is when i talk to people about
religion what i'm really really
interested in is
more of i i understand the story of
jesus and i've looked into it and i've
looked into the romans who are alive
during that day and it's compelling
enough for me to understand like this
guy
really had an impact of the people who
were alive back then and to me from the
research that i've done and i could do
more
it points towards him being very very
very important and potentially the son
of god and that's that's there
um what i what i my personal interest is
uh
way before then and i'm really
interested in god himself and i know
that they're connected and everything
you know but i don't really know that
god has a physical body i kind of just
think he might be like a mind and jesus
is the physical embodiment of him and
there's a spirit between them there's
the three whatever
i'm really really interested in
god himself and who he is and his you
know
when jesus before the time of jesus or
his physical body so uh continue i want
to hear what he had to say yeah so
if i'm not going to go too deep into
into jesus in the old testament and not
the old testament the new testament and
all of that and those beliefs in paul uh
and the church fathers council nicea i'm
not going to go into all of that because
i don't think it would be
i don't think it's necessary at least
for this episode so
what i want to ask you rather
is
would you agree with the statement that
uh
if there are truths to know about god
we
aside from the basic logical deductions
we can make like he must exist he must
be all powerful right and so on and so
forth
um
do you believe there are things about
god that we can only know if he revealed
to us
oh certainly yeah yeah i think yeah
that's a given for sure okay perfect so
would you also agree that if god were to
send a religion or revelation or
something it would be obvious it would
be clear
oh yeah
okay perfect so and you don't ascribe to
any particular religion right you say
christian but like again i guess we
established that you you wouldn't
actually be a christian
yeah yeah i i'm really um
i'm really like trying to
i guess i'm i guess i'm trying to be
somebody after god's heart if that makes
sense i know that there's one you know
and um and i would say that i'm i would
say that i'm a christian but i wouldn't
say i'm a christian in the way that the
world and the worldly sense if that
makes sense okay okay yeah that's that's
great that's great and i want to say
this now eventually i want to get to the
topic of adam and eve and all of that
because you mentioned it briefly when my
camera just
died for some reason it's not even on a
battery but it somehow still died but uh
we'll get to that but what i what i want
to introduce to you now is the concept
of islam because me and fayad
we came from a place where we were born
into islam like we're muslims but we
were never really practicing and what
really got us to practice islam
were certain you know personal moments
in our lives individually but overall
everything it was the the logical and
rational proof and evidence that pointed
uh towards islam being true and the
prophet muhammad peace be upon him being
a true prophet of god and what i love
overall about islam is it gives the
perfect explanation not just the
universe and not just like arguments
explaining the universe and how we came
to be in everything and counter
arguments atheist beliefs and polytheism
but it actually it brings all the
the historical
points in time that are not all of them
but the ones that are mentioned in the
quran and it ties them perfectly
together with the claim that
god sent prophets
with the message to worship one god
alone and you can see this from adam
peace be upon him to noah to abraham to
isaac and ismael to moses and um
the children of israel david solomon
jesus and the prophet muhammad be upon
him
but the difference is because there are
different religions and everything we
claim that these religions were sent
from god initially with the belief that
you worship one god alone you don't
associate pardons with them you know the
first commandment in both
what's called judaism and christianity
and the shahada the testimony of faith
in islam that there's no god that you
should worship except god alone allah
right
and we say that the reason you see these
discrepancies in the in the faith is
because people over time they change the
book and you can see in the difference
between the talmud and the torah there
are contradictions between them
and we can get into that later on and
with the you know the new testament in
and of itself and how that even
contradicts the old testament and all
these discrepancies we say that those
were mistakes and those were done by men
by people who wanted to interpret the
faith in their own way or add things
that
were never there and you can see that
with jesus peace be upon him as well and
we say that the prophet muhammad peace
be upon him was the last and final
messenger
that he came with the last message to
worship one god alone and to submit to
him fully and know that you will return
to him
and one philosophical argument just a
side note is that we were dead at one
point we didn't exist and then randomly
we came to life
we know we're gonna die
why do we not think that we're gonna
randomly come to life again after that
that's just a little side note of a
philosophical argument made by one
famous philosopher but i forgot who the
name what the name is but essentially
islam takes all these different things
throughout history we see
with the babylon of babylonians
worshiped and the quran describes it
accurately
the sun the moon and then like a a
celestial object but i believe it was
venus actually
and and the quran describes ibrahim and
his people and and how he gave dawa to
them and taught them basically not to
worship these things and how he actually
sarcastically turned to them and he's
like you know this moon i'm gonna take
it as my god and then when it's set he's
like i don't like the fact that it sets
how is it god then he went to a
celestial body and said the same thing
and until it went out of sight he
couldn't see it anymore
and then he went to the sun he's like
this is the most grand of them all it
must be god
and that's that as well and he's like
i i unsubscribed from all these beliefs
and he told his people all your idols
all your beliefs are are enemies to me
except for the
lord of mankind so i see that everything
or most of your views in regards to
to god
i would say islam perfectly encapsulates
the history of certain places
and why there are certain discrepancies
but lines up with the claim of it being
the last religion from god the last
major religion to arise to be honest and
sikhism is a different story we can get
into that
that still
claims that we should worship one god
alone so my question to you would be
have you looked into islam and do you
have any contentions with islam
uh
no contentions right now um
really
it's crazy because you know these uh
topics are so deep you could you know
people spend a lifetime studying one
particular thing of one religion and
they never learned everything
so most of my research has really been
way far back in the old testament um
but you are right uh when you say that
it does seem like the old testament in
the new testament um it's a different it
seems like it's a different god
in some of them sometimes and uh any
christian who says that you know you
talk to uh one point of contention with
christians as you you tell them that the
bible has been tampered with and they go
no it hasn't no there's no way i'm like
okay well why don't we have the story of
of jesus from the time that he's 12
until he's like 32 or something like
that you know i think it's the book of
tom or thomas where it talks about him
as a child and you know where'd the book
of enoch go where did all these other
books go that the roman catholic church
didn't want it oh that's what it is the
roman catholic church you know it's like
yeah so you guys are yeah you guys are
spot on about that um
the history of christianity uh has been
touched you know what i mean and uh has
has been touched and edited and um
it is a strong point uh that islam has
that
they're um
that their word as far as i know i don't
know anybody who's trying to say that
otherwise but hasn't been tampered with
yeah you know has not been yeah and we
have an abundance of evidence and we
even have a list a chain of narrations
or a chain of narrators a chain of
people who have actually memorized the
quran from cover to cover and people
might ask like oh how can they remember
as entirely there are children
alive today that are memorized
oh yeah yeah they can literally write it
all themselves but it's amazing it's
found a lot but we have a chain of
people who memorize it going back to the
prophet himself peace be upon him and we
actually have um multiple manuscripts
including uh an uthmani manuscript from
which is actually i believe cover to
cover the full quran
from the time of the leadership of one
of the companions of the prophet peace
be upon him that would be the equivalent
to having like the full gospel of mark
that we knew was actually that can be
traced back to mark and jesus himself
peace be upon him but we have most of
the masters of christianity come from
like the ninth century which is way too
far off but islam is like second
generation third generation literally
still linked to the prophet just be upon
him
so
in regards to that it definitely checks
it off and you know the amazing part is
um i mentioned before and i asked it for
a very specific reason because these are
beliefs that muslims have as well about
god and his religion would be clear it'd
be obvious kind of unbelievable allah he
actually says in the quran that the
truth is distinct from falsehood
you look at the truth and you look at
falsehood and you're like i know which
one like beats the heck out of the other
one right and the quran allah he
actually says that we have sent down the
reminder and we will surely preserve it
we will definitely preserve it so that
claim in and of itself and seeing how it
survived perfectly for 1400 years is
amazing and there are some other claims
i want to get into later but
i do want to keep going and exploring
your views personally that um
like
let's say that there was a religion
right that was true are you in search of
that religion or of any religion because
you say you predominantly look at like
history
and and certain i would say certain
events in history in certain beliefs
throughout history and you tie it to one
god but that isn't exactly ascertaining
truth about you know
what belief you should have today it's
more so just seeing what variety of
people believed in and we already agreed
that if there's is this truth that ought
to be known
about god it would come from god himself
right
yeah no i totally agree with that um
well i'd say
it would be dumb to say
everything everything in my past is
screaming to say no no you're looking
for the truth of christianity um but it
would be dumb of me to say i wasn't
looking for the actual truth you know
and um whatever that might be
uh
for instance right now i'm actually um
i'm not mormon but i'm actually reading
the book of mormon and um when i this is
probably my first step outside of
traditional christianity starting to
look into some other things and
so right now i'm reading the book of
mormon and the point of view i'm taking
from it is
um okay
every
city that it talks about every person
that it talks about we're gonna
cross-reference i'm gonna find is there
any evidence that this place really
existed is there any evidence that these
people really existed and in the
americas it's a lot harder because um
you know in the old world where uh you
know the quran and the bible take place
everything is made out of stone and rock
and here in the americas everything's
made out of wood so things deteriorate
over time so it's harder to put together
but
um
i'd say
the deeper i dive into it the more i
realize things aren't the way i thought
that they were and i would just say
i'm just looking for the actual truth
you know what i mean it doesn't make me
question jesus
yet i haven't gotten there i haven't
gotten to a point where i'm starting to
question the story of jesus i i'm pretty
convicted
um and this isn't me trying to come on
yelp's podcast and say anything about
jesus or whatever um
but i'm pretty convicted of the
experiences of the roman people at the
time and uh
in particular the centurion and what he
had to say about his interactions with
jesus and the guy that stabbed him uh
and the water bled on him and he became
uh and it fixed his blindness and then
he became a saint and everything i'm i
find it all pretty convincing
but
just answer your question yeah i'm
looking for the actual truth i'm not
trying to be biased at all
and so when i discover things
and thoroughly research them that
counter the views that i've had i'm not
i'm not a i'm not like a traditional
academic who's going to fight tooth and
nail for everything to fit with my
perceived views you know what i mean
yeah yeah and honestly that's something
i really do appreciate because a lot of
people including muslims are they're
very biased they're very kind of strict
in their own view and they're not
willing to
go outside their their comfort zone and
look for truth you know outside and it's
funny because in islam we have a concept
of iman and people usually translate it
as faith but it's not faith it's
actually um conviction and a fact
that's that has basis and evidence in
reality so for us to have iman as
muslims it basically has to be a man as
muslims it basically has to be proven to
us that islam is the truth so for
muslims to kind of take that bias role
is actually really unfortunate but
again i really do appreciate what you
said and this is the tricky part because
you can have aspects of a religion or
aspects of something that is true
without the whole thing being true
so just because you find a few things or
i found a few things in a particular
religion that may may be proven to be
false right logically or ontologically
or empirically whatever
it doesn't mean that everything in the
religion is actually false i think
that's the most difficult part about
looking throughout history because you
one you don't know what's actually
accurate because the job of historian is
to see what most likely happened but
there's never 100 certainty unless it's
like recorded on footage or something
like that so you have that difficulty
you have the difficulty of piecing
everything together and seeing what
actually happened what's actually true
and you don't know if what you're
reading is is accurate if it's
fabricated or which parts of it are so i
think that is is a huge stepping stone
for a lot of people looking for the
truth especially when it comes to
religion and god
i agree with romney bro um luke by the
way one of the main reasons we invited
you on too was we felt the pull after
seeing your videos that you think
outside the box and that's why i keep
stressing you that you know we want you
to think we want you to really ask the
questions and and be unbiased and want
the objective truth so if you don't want
you know us to you know publish this
episode or anything our main priority is
not that our main priority is really you
and really having a deep conversation
with you um relating to jesus we don't
disbelieve in jesus so i do think there
are some things we can talk about later
um eventually in the podcast because
people think that muslims don't believe
in jesus um when rami was talking about
you know ibrahim peace be upon him which
was prophet abraham uh when he came and
you know talked to his people about you
know the truth being sent by god and why
are you worshiping the sun and the moon
and all that there's a lot of
similarities i also want to say that
that allah when god talks in the quran
about objective reality he doesn't say
oh believe this believe that in the
quran it says know this or know that
because there's aspects of us and
elements within us that resonate with
the truth because we really are
creations of god so they're not foreign
things to us it's kind of like your
conscience or your your gut instinct um
in islam we call it the fitra which is
our innate predisposition so when you
read these things and come across these
things they don't they don't have to be
things that you have to force yourself
to kind of like okay i believe in this
but it's kind of like a confusing thing
i want to just you know i don't want to
look at it too much it's like an
elephant in the room but you almost know
it and there's like unequivocal doubt um
and conviction that this is true
yeah no it's very poignant um
yeah it's really interesting there's
something
not to deter but uh sort of what rami
was just saying is uh
when you were talking about how
religions you know they have this
starting point and they change over time
um
what i thought what i think is really
interesting is and a belief of mine is
that
you know you hear about like the epic of
gilgamesh and noah's ark and you hear
all these stories that sound kind of
kind of uh similar like the earth is
being destroyed and um and we hear all
these very similar stories and there's
even
there's even
people who study greek mythology roman
mythology egyptian mythology they
connect to them to
they can be connected to judaism in
particular and and you start to see
similar characters all over the place
and a thought that i have that i don't
know that people can
i'm not sure if there's an answer to
this but um
after the time of the flood
the it's it people theorize that the ark
landed in mesopotamia and i'm not sure
if you guys believe um in the in the in
the flood event or that people
survive the flood but as a christian
it's interesting
people landed in uh they believe that
the ark landed in mesopotamia and that
people began to permeate from there
because about 10 000 years ago we see
structures that are built in mesopotamia
and then they permeate over to
northeast africa where egypt is and they
start going down to asia and they go up
to europe as well well
if those people were the descendants of
noah then they certainly knew about the
they certainly knew about the
you know the one true god the you know
the monotheist god you know whatever we
want to call him yahweh allah you know
they certainly knew about him
but you know as
more and more and more people are being
born
well that's going to slowly kind of
permeate and change and there's only
going to be little remnants of that left
does that make any kind of sense and so
as you're as i researched through these
uh different religions and the things
that people believe at the time i start
to realize i start to see vague
connections i'm like you know what
maybe they maybe there's some small
truth here you know maybe these are
connected and uh you start drawing
connections all over the place when you
start getting into that but
i mean man this is the only earth that
as far as i know that human beings have
lived on and billions of us have lived
here so there's so much history and
there's so many possibilities and this
is just the result of you know billions
of people living on this planet and all
believing you know all believing
something different and so
um i'm just i'm trying to find the truth
somewhere in all of this does that make
sense
yeah yeah and again that's something i
really do appreciate i think it's
actually honorable because that's
something i haven't even done myself
looking at various you know
events in history various people
various artifacts and everything uh
about what they believed and how they
lived and and and all that stuff and
linking them together because as someone
who
rationally and logically is convicted of
islam
i personally don't need that for my
faith because i i personally believe i
have the truth
and because i personally believe that
everything i now look at in life or most
things i look at with the criterion of
of that is that islam basically that
belief so even if i do look at certain
historical events and these things
i will most likely only look at it
through that lens of islam that it does
this um comply with islam like these
people believed in maybe you know
multiple gods or something i'm gonna say
that be like okay that's cool they
believed in it but that doesn't mean
it's true
when i when i look at things as a muslim
when muslims look at things because the
quran is also called the criterion but
um
that's just that's just a side note that
i personally i believe that if you have
that religion from god i mean logically
it follows this world if you have the
religion from god then you don't need
anything else because it wouldn't be a
true religion if it wasn't fully
complete
you know what i mean yeah bro that's the
thing i don't like that's why i don't
want people hearing um the side note
that you're mentioning that okay doesn't
that just make him then you know kind of
like a fallacy of you know just
believing in whatever he believes in and
now he's going to believe in anything
else he's not open to anything else so
so
what would you say to that romney
because a lot of people might hear that
and they're like okay is he one of those
uh you know i'm too scared to see
another religion or research into other
religions because he just wants to you
know live in his blue pill world yeah
yeah i'm glad you mentioned that because
it is a very important a very important
question i was actually going to talk
about it but i didn't want to keep going
on so
uh the quran itself actually has this
precedent i think is amazing it says
that this is the book that has been
revealed in it are verses that are clear
cut right they can only be understood in
one way right and others are ambiguous
they're speculative
they could be understood in different
ways um and so and so on and so forth he
says that the clear verses are the
foundation of the book
so the president is the president is
basically that that which is clear cut
will be the foundation and anything as
speculative can only be built upon that
so
the reason i start off by saying islam
has been logically rationally proven to
me is because
that is the foundation that it's not
just something i believe it's something
i have a man in it's something that has
been logically rationally proven to me
to be a religion from god because it's
not possible that a man or any even even
any civilization even america could
produce a book like that and we can go
into that later so once i have that
that understanding and i know that islam
is the religion from god that gives me
the precedence to look at everything
else that's doubtful because history is
is heavily doubtful in some cases more
than others if you look at recent
american history that's more sure but if
you look at perhaps thousands of years
ago well how could you possibly
fully understand
basically how they lived what they
believed and everything especially when
you're dealing with with the writings of
people because you're getting their
uh perception of it and you know as they
say uh you see history through the eyes
of the victor
that there's a huge part of history with
every war every battle every fight
that's ever occurred that you most
likely only see the side that one and
how do you know they're speaking the
full truth because they see themselves
as the heroes they're gonna say that you
know the other side they were evil they
were disgusting they were vile they were
horrible and we
relinquish the earth of those animals
but how do you know that the people who
are saying that aren't the true animals
so there's so many aspects to it that
you need to have for any belief in life
you have to have a premise you have to
have a foundation and since islam has
been largely rationally proven to me i
use that as the foundation so it's not
just some kind of belief in circular
argument and echo chamber
i hope that makes sense
no no yeah it makes it makes perfect
sense so uh one thing this might lead to
another rabbit hole um but what you were
saying about it's been
logically proven to you one of the
things that i am really fascinated in
and i'm interested in hearing um if you
guys believe something similar or what
your beliefs are in this
so
if you guys ever watched the show like
ancient aliens all these there are a
bunch of scientists and a bunch of
people who
uh believe that
i don't even know if you guys believe in
like evolutionary biology i'm not sure
what your opinions are i i am one of the
few christians that believe in
evolutionary biology i think the earth
has been around for so ridiculously long
and the human being's only been here for
a short period of that um but what's
really interesting is though when you
start to look at history and you start
to study it and you
things start to take a lot longer to
develop
and a lot of these scientists they have
figured out the
um
i guess the the evolutionary lifespan or
the evolutionary span of of all
different types of animals but
there's something that's well known
called the missing link and we don't
really know
how human beings became the way that we
are because it's like it happens in the
blink of an eye according to evolution
because they found skeletons of what
comes right
of what has come before us buried
alongside us and people don't they can't
understand well how did human beings
evolve so fast
and so there's a theory out there that
oh well aliens must have came and
modified the human race and made us the
way we are i think scientology has has a
similar viewpoint to that well what's
really interesting
is when you look into genesis it says
that the um
it says that at one time the the sons of
god saw that the daughters of men were
fair and good and took to them wives as
many as they chose and bore children to
them
and
you know you start to see
everything starts to change after that
point and then you can kind of connect
that to the story of adam and eve and
and the belief that i'm starting to come
to is
you know i wonder if this apple that eve
is is being seduced to um
to eat is some is referencing something
a little more sexual in nature rather
than just a fruit and the bible does
this a lot and i think it i don't think
it's the only religion that references
fruit in a sexual way
and i'm starting to wonder if
because you know the serpent she
the serpent he
seduced eve saying that she will become
like him she'll be one like him and um
and he was pleasing to her eye
as is what the is what the old testament
says and i i believe i'm starting to
sort of fall into or story starting to
find more um interesting is i wonder if
there's some truth to what scientists
say that human beings must have been
modified in some type of way but i don't
think it was little green men that came
and
uh messed with us i think that the gene
i think that the gene pool
got contaminated with sin and people
were becoming born half physical body
half demonic and so they have this
sinful nature uh automatically and so
that is sort of how just in an instant
our our dna changed and so when you say
that you come to your beliefs logically
and that are backed by science that's
sort of the the approach i take i look
at all of it and i'm like what of this
fits together there's a huge puzzle here
and it's got to make sense you know what
i mean they're ha it has to make sense
it can't just not make sense and we
can't just be here
by accident and um so anyways i was
going to say before rami jumps in that
that's listen being a a medical student
taking years of science courses and
i'm i'm going to say this oh you're
totally right we've made we've made an
episode um
specifically on your question should
muslims believe in evolution right and
it's not what most muslims think because
if if you're muslim and you're this
you're to say that you know evolution is
false at least all types of evolution is
false you have no idea what you're
talking about i'm going to say this
right now
that's why we literally got an islamic
scholar who's also an evolutionary
biologist to basically connect the dots
there's a whole stigma that we don't
believe in evolution we might not
believe in darwinian evolution but
to to just refute evolution as a whole
we go we go deep into that so if you do
want to check that out i'll give you the
link after anyone watching it i highly
recommend you check that out um yeah i'd
love to waste time on this uh podcast
but i do wanna allow me to go in because
when we say logically or rationally
convicted it's not gonna be that you
know blind faith or there's things that
don't add up everything that is aligned
with islam is aligned with reality
but we're coming from a point that
everything that mainstream science
thinks is reality necessarily might not
be
yeah but i'll be going
oh yeah so i want to touch on the point
there so first and foremost even
darwinian evolution even though our
world in evolution as a mechanism we
don't have a problem with as muslims the
only real contention islam has with the
idea of evolution is that we evolve from
something else
and now i wanna i wanna go into this a
little bit so
without speaking on dar um on evolution
too much
it's amazing the points you mentioned
because as you mentioned them i'm like
this
ties into islam so perfectly the beliefs
we have in islam so like so perfectly so
it's not in the it's not in the sense
that
um there were things like there's a
species and then eve had like you know
basically got with that species that it
reproduced
and their genetics combined
but there are some overlapping troops i
would say so in uh
in uh what's it called
what's it called in evolution sorry
there is a period in time where a bunch
of different species started popping up
at one point in time i forget what it's
called but uh there's there's a
video out there with us two philosophers
of science and one i think evolutionary
biologist or scientist
and they talk about the problem of
darwinism and how it doesn't actually
answer the question of of how things
evolved when you look at this specific
point in time because they essentially
say that the protein you need to produce
a new gene a variant gene a mutated gene
occurs
so rare so rarely that to have all these
different species pop up and one time it
doesn't make sense that's that's firstly
so there are things in science that they
believed maybe a few years ago or
decades ago that now we believe the
complete opposite of so even standard
scientific narrative
could lead you to falsehood which is
crazy because there is a time when they
believe that um the sun was stationary
while the quran said it has an orbit so
people back then were saying look your
quran says it has an orbit you guys are
dumb and then they found out look the
sun actually has a small orbit it's just
the closest to the center of the
universe so
a little nuances like that but to talk
about the islamic belief
so we don't say that the earth was
created like 6000 years ago or something
like like the bible i believe it's
written
we believe that allah created the
heavens the earth the universe and all
that at one point in time with
uh we and we don't contend with the big
bang model or anything like that we just
believe that allah created the universe
in the heavens the earth at one point in
time
and uh
not six days it mentions six periods and
these periods could be as long or as
small as needed so it says yom yom can
mean a day a period of day but it could
mean a period of a thousand years or
whatever time period you want to talk
about so we don't have a problem with
big bang or anything like that so we
believe that the earth already existed
it was inhabited with species and
animals and and it's amazing that the
quran particularly mentions
that god announced the angels he's going
to make a new creation on earth a new uh
uh
like a new leader on earth
and the angels asked
are you going to create another creation
that sheds blood and does this and that
and they describe that there has been a
creation already that's similar to
humans
but that weren't exactly humans now the
standard belief is that this is what we
call the jinn
which you know people would call demons
or ghosts or whatever but we call we
believe that there's another creation
allah created before mankind called the
jinn but in the episode you'll hear that
he mentions that this actually could be
alluding to
animals or creatures that are similar to
humans but not actually humans and
perhaps they were animals and then to
have humans pop in at one point which is
what you mentioned science kind of
essentially establishes that they kind
of popped in at one point in time
doesn't go against the idea that god
created adam and eve at that point in
time or created humans at a particular
point in time for us that's yeah that's
crazy man cause that's so true uh a lot
of people think that
um
it's so interesting a lot of people
think that human beings came from uh i'm
blanking right now uh not then
uh neanderthals i was about to say
nephilim um but a lot of people believe
that human beings came from the
neanderthals but we didn't we're just
related to them they're way off in the
distance and
human beings aren't really related to a
lot um not really related to much we
don't really know you know it but you're
right it um
scientists and religious people
all agree that human beings just poop
we're here and it's
very strange isn't it yeah yeah bro the
check also mentioned that um
human beings share i believe 87 of the
the genes with bananas it doesn't mean
we came from bananas right it just means
there's there's similarities in the
whole epigenetic structure and all that
um and it also doesn't answer the whole
question of that mass divergent
speciation that rami was talking about
yeah yeah and bro there are so many
problems with evolution like think about
the eyeball the eyeball is only proper
when it's fully functioning how could
the eyeball evolve you're going to have
holes in your head and then there's
these little gooey things and eventually
certain parts form and then the pupil
forms and and then
the eyelids and the eyelashes and
eyebrows and all these things form over
time it's only fully functioning when
it's all together so to have it evolve
based on natural selection well to have
these giant gaping gooey holes in your
head is not very um uh functionable it's
not a very
um it's not a very strong characteristic
to have in the animal kingdom so yeah
and bro the whole the whole theory of
natural selection as a whole goes
against the law of entropy yeah you're
going from a whole world of chaos and
disorder and you're diverging into
functionality and and this systemic
mechanism of function it kind of makes
no sense bro yeah and on top of that
just to kind of keep piling on on the
discrepancy designs is it doesn't answer
how life got on earth because natural
selection through random mutation
implies that there's already life to
mutate there's ready genes to mutate and
i know they have different ideas and
beliefs on how you know life originally
i hadn't even thought of that yeah yeah
that's crazy to think about because
um
golly i can't uh it's before the
cambrian uh period but um
when they say that there was nothing but
you know life in the sea well
even i i i'm just realizing now that
there have always had to be life it
can't just
come from nowhere you know what i mean
and it's so obvious it sounds so obvious
but it's just now dawning on me because
i've been thinking you know oh well you
know eventually these lizard-like
creatures got out of the ocean onto land
and everything but then you keep going
back further and further and further and
it's like well at some point it just has
to bloop and be there regardless of what
you believe whether it's you know all
the animals in the way that they are and
human beings existed at one time we just
appeared here or we slowly evolved over
time it had to be planted you know what
i mean
life had to be planted so that's really
uh that's i hadn't even thought of that
it's very interesting yeah i want to
recommend to you two books um one is
more specific to darwinism it's called
darwin's doubt by stephen myers and
another one is is another book he wrote
called signature in the cell where he
argues that um because of the
complexities we have and these like
literal literal like little biological
machines we're created with that there
basically has to be a god that designed
us so those two books are amazing both
by stephen a meyer but um he references
these things right at the start of the
book the problem of how life got on
earth and the problem of entropy and
he's one of the the philosophers of
science i mentioned that are in the
video that i recommended that everyone
watch um called the math i think it's
called the mathematical problems with
darwinism something like that but yeah
so
this just is i would say proof towards
the fact that science
doesn't even really aim to
prove or to to derive truth it more so
aims to understand how things work and
they drive theories and all that from
empirical evidences and they try and
take all the evidence and link it to a
theory that encompasses all the evidence
and as soon as they get more evidence
they find the theory doesn't work they
make a new one that's why there's been
so many mechanisms and understandings of
of evolution as a whole because
evolution is such a broad term things
evolving things changing over time so
there's like neo-genetics neo-darwinism
all these different things and perhaps
the the true answer is a combination of
these different mechanisms but we'll
never
like fully know from a scientific
perspective so i think that is is
phenomenal and an important point to
make as well um
but
you you mentioned before
that the apple is basically like
uh eve being seduced and then having
offspring with this other creation right
and um
and also aliens
kind of corrupting our gene pool in a
way that created human beings
that is let's let's say that that is a
possibility
there could be i would say multiple
other possibilities as well all of which
line up with the evidence we have it's
we're basically doing like scientific
theories here right
so
no one can know for certain no one can
know 100 exactly what happened
unless it was revealed to us
from from god himself or there was some
like way some evidence that was just
undeniable so
no matter where you go
it almost always leads you back to
religion i would say
which is what i was trying to say this
this is why i started my whole like not
speech but like a little lecture because
i've been talking for a long time i
started off with saying that islam no
matter where you look you always find
that it perfectly encapsulates the i
would say the more surely known facts
the more surely known things from adam
and eve peace be upon them to like
babylon and noah's ark it's actually
it's amazing you mentioned that this is
what i was going to say before we
believe that it landed um on a mount a
mountain called mount judi and that's
actually a mountain in turkey if you
look up mountain judy judi you'll find a
lot of pictures of this like crevice
this boat shaped crevice
which i think it's like it's amazing a
lot of the quran says it meant it ended
or landed on mount judi and um
it's uh yeah you can see a little
crevice there that's a little side note
but um yeah yeah i've seen that i think
something recently just came up about
that in the news as well oh yeah
what was that i'm not i'm not sure i'm
not sure what it was i i think that they
um
they drilled into the they drilled into
the rock and they found that it was uh
petrified wood and they found like cat
hair and and uh golly i want to say like
woolly mammoth hair all kinds of crazy
stuff in this uh petrified um wood so
yeah it's pretty fascinating
i'm not sure if i said earlier that uh
people believe that the ark landed in
mesopotamia i'm not saying that's
exactly what i believe i don't really
a lot of the stuff i look into it
because i find it interesting but i
don't form
really hard opinions on it because it
changes you know um but that's really
interesting yeah
what's even more fascinating was the
thing that rami was talking about about
jin so this is something that's not
talked about in other religions too so i
want to say clearly that in islam we
believe that there are two creations
that have free will obviously angels
don't have free will right but they're
still creation of allah
we have jin and human beings right but
the thing with jin is they're they're
not from this dimension they are extra
dimensional we can't see them but they
could see us and that's the thing
there's deep ties in in the occult and
you know we we call it satan shaitaan
and all that um we believe satan was a
was a jinn by the way so in other
religions satan was among the angels so
he was thought to be of the angels but
we know satan to be a jinn
who's just one of the best jin and he
was raised in rank but not raised among
the angels but to be among the angels
not because he's from them if that makes
sense um furthermore jin have deep ties
in the music industry so we're actually
going to make an episode soon that's
going to drop showing how music itself
there's like it literally takes like the
pentagram and puts it in like sonics and
sound production that's a whole other
rabbit hole that we're not gonna get
into but if you do want to go into that
you can check that out um but again in
islam music is haram or impermissible so
muslims we shouldn't listen to music
especially musical instruments so to
speak but when you look at other
religions there's not many i guess
specificities around music
yeah i also want to say that i'm saying
this because i know in a video you
mentioned that when you talked about
stairway to heaven um it's almost like
the artist was like he just lifted the
pen and he just started writing after he
felt possessed and we believe that to
also be linked to jin so jin are what
possesses us right so they possess us
they need to be exercised um just like
normal exorcisms you see in christianity
and all that except you know we call it
which is exorcism there's also
scientific studies that show that people
that have a lot of mental illnesses um
like depersonalization uh panic disorder
schizo and all this once they do rokya
and they get the exorcism done they
actually subside from a lot of these
symptoms so i'm not saying x equals y
but i'm saying there's definitely a
correlation between mental health or
mental dysfunction and gin possession
wow that that is uh that is really
fascinating
yeah it's i have to look into that
because you see in in music it's so
prevalent that people
have these alter egos and they say that
it's like this spirit that comes into
their body and guides what they do and
you in
even jim morrison he was a guy who was
well known for being uh possessed he
would come out and talk about it that he
would possess himself with demons and
and that's really yeah it's very
fascinating um it's called jin
yeah j-i-n-and so here's
spirits these are all jin right in islam
we have jin and and there's very clear
verses and and you know in the surahs in
the quran in the chapters in the quran
speaking about jinn it's not something
that we shy away from whatsoever um
matter of fact you know we we have daily
you know recitations where we where we
pray to allah for protection against
jinn um and all that they're associated
with like evil eye black magic
witchcraft and all that because they do
exist specific stories like prophet
solomon uh peace be upon him using jinn
and there's there's no shying away from
reality whether it be anecdotal
experiences or things that are
scientifically proven so i do think that
gin should be something that you do some
research on
yeah i definitely will so
sorry this is just a christian
question but um
do you guys believe that
allah created the jinn to be his
antithesis you know to be against him is
that what is that what they are
so
we believe that allah that god spent
glory be to him created both
man and jin kind
mankind in kind
in a way where they have free will and
where they're being tested in this life
and god specifically says in the quran
that he did not create mankind or jin
kind except to worship him so jinn is
not in any way
the opposite opposition antithesis or
anything of god they're a creation of
god they are subordinate to god they are
dependent upon god and they are only
here to worship him the same way we are
only here to worship him
in islam we don't have any
antithesis to god at all everything else
that exists other than god
is basically just
subordinate to him
and as one person said this is not an
islamic claim but i guess you can
understand this way but god is literal
everything else is metaphorical because
without god like nothing else exists
ontologically and and theologically and
otherwise
yeah i totally i totally agree with that
all right
we're coming up on an hour unfortunately
bro i don't want it to end um yeah i
feel i feel like i was i was watching
the time and i was like we've we've just
barely scratched the surface of things
that we could talk about i could talk to
you guys for the next eight hours easy
yeah yeah um listen we definitely will
do this again but before we do wrap it
up do you have any more questions or
anything that's still on your mind
that's fresh because we don't want it to
be something that you forget or
something that's left and unaddressed
um
um
well he would go to lead us down another
rabbit hole um i'm i'm really interested
in
y'all's opinion of the
well not opinion but
what you believe as far as the time of
the flood because if we talk in the
future i definitely want to speak about
that
yeah 100 percent so when you say the
time of the flood do you mean like which
era it took it took place
well okay okay so um earlier you said i
didn't want to stop you because you were
on a roll uh but uh you said that um
somewhere in the bible it says that the
earth is about six thousand years old it
doesn't explicitly say that but if you
if you go back if you yeah if you follow
the genealogy it'll lead you back six
thousand years there are some
discrepancies there and and and i
certainly don't agree with that
because the younger driest event which
happened about um 11 600 years ago is
what actually flooded that side of the
earth and i believe um there there's
people can get into how that how that
happened but it's pretty much a fact
that it happened and when it happened
was roughly about ten thousand years ago
um ten thousand to twelve thousand
and
i just find that time really interesting
for a lot of different reasons but i'm
just curious where you guys
place that event
and um and if you believe that just one
family survived it or if you believe
that maybe other people survived as well
okay so those are great questions those
are great questions so first and
foremost the quran doesn't explicitly
state um which time period it occurred
in or anything like that but what we do
know is that
there's two opinions the first opinion
is that the whole world was flooded and
that's a biblical opinion as well but
muslims are know with upon no obligation
to believe that which is why the other
opinion as which is also a classical
opinion is that there is only a certain
part of the earth that was flooded and
the reason this got misinterpreted is
because we believe this flood happened
so early on in humanity that humankind
didn't go beyond
basically
the i would say
a certain geographical area that adam
and eve were sent down to or where they
where they met up because we believe
they were actually sent to different
parts of the earth and had to find each
other it's a you know beautiful love
story think about it but um
that where they met and then where the
offspring were basically came about we
called noah the second father of mankind
because
that flood we believe or one opinion is
that only took place in one part and
that basically all the disbelievers on
the face of earth were wiped out except
for noah and a few he had a handful of
followers and then all the offspring
actually came from his his descendants
after that but again we don't put a
certain time period so there was a big
flood in in the i would say in that part
of the earth eastern part of the earth
uh perhaps ten thousand years ago that's
what you said right ten thousand
yeah it's believed to be about eleven
thousand six hundred years ago it's
called the younger driest event you
could you could look into it um yeah it
they
they note that they're able to estimate
that because if you you could even go on
google earth and look at it
if you go to
uh western africa like northwest africa
you can see the ripples of the terrain
and it looks like it's being pulled back
into the ocean and you can and um and
geologists when they look at it you can
tell that water was rushed up onto that
side of the world and it pushed all of
the sand from the ocean up and then it
drug it back down into the ocean over a
long period of time
and
i'm not i really don't know if the whole
earth was flooded that that's a lot of
land to cover maybe maybe for maybe um
you know
well i mean the flood was pretty short
uh 40 days and 40 nights according to
christianity that's not that long of a
time i
you know i don't know um
it could have been the whole world but i
know for sure that entire side of the
world was completely destroyed and i'm
actually of the belief
uh that humanity
this is sort of the whole purpose behind
my youtube channel and i'm just now sort
of
thinking of the right way to say this in
this podcast
is i believe that god had to destroy
mankind at the time because they were so
advanced and
the things that they were doing were so
horrendous that it all needed to be
destroyed so i think that there were
likely
millions of people on the earth and i
think that their knowledge
uh in some things far surpasses what we
know today and i think it was so wicked
and uh so advanced that god had to
destroy it and i i'm actually uh
there are other people who who agree
with this that the the great pyramids
and that um a lot of other structures
that they were they were around before
the time of the flood and they had some
kind of some kind of uh energy purpose
whether it's like um electricity or
whatnot um yeah so that's sort of
something we can get into one day in the
future a lot of people you know claim
that that jin were you know people use
gen to create pyramids and all that um
so i i do want to talk in in the next
episode about all the things um jesus
specifically we didn't really go into
jesus peace be upon him uh i do want to
talk about the gel too so in in islam
the jal is you guys known as the
antichrist um it's not a metaphor you
know so a lot of people think it's a
metaphor the jo is coming just like you
know isa
jesus peace be upon him we'll return to
um and these are things that were very
specified they were with excruciating
detail too um there's a lot of links
today in the jawlic uh you know
occultism and all that so we can
definitely go into that too
you mentioned something earlier that uh
that i was thinking but it kind of stood
my mind right now um but yeah if i do
remember i'll mention it uh aside from
that do either of you have anything else
to say
uh
go ahead go ahead okay okay uh so
before i forget so
what do you guys believe
i'm actually i actually believe
when you when you follow the bible uh
the first time that you actually hear of
a tool being mentioned or something that
was created by blacksmithing is um when
when adam and eve are cast out of the
garden of eden there is a flaming sword
that's put in front of the garden of
eden and up until then you never hear
about technology or blacksmithing but
then you learn that hmm there's already
swords existing before people have
created them and then that sort of ties
into and i thought that you said it was
interesting that a lot of people
speculate that maybe human beings used
the gin or that the gin may have taught
people how to build things
that aligns perfectly with
what i'm really interested in and what
i'm starting to believe is that
human beings and these fallen angels i
call them
lived very closely amongst one another
and probably the technology that we have
today
was
or the technology that they had back
then was given to them and they were
taught how to use it and there's just a
lot of things um
we'll make that the next episode yeah
let me let me mention this this one
thing to you too that because it just
came back to me um so
we were speaking with another brother
ahmed khan he has his own podcast and we
were talking about the
i believe it was the physicist that came
out with the the perfect equation needed
to
allow satellites to finally break out of
the stratosphere i forgot who it was i
believe it was jack parsons or something
like that and in a dream he's been
trying to crack the code for a long time
but he couldn't and he finally had a
dream where it basically dawned upon him
the the numbers that he needed um and
definitely we can we can check this up
later um and he spoke to the entity that
gave him that that number that finally
helped him with that revolution and he
was like who are you and and he said by
name i am the jal
the jal in islam
1400 years ago i was being told that
this is going to be the antichrist that
comes this was specified this was well
documented this is something nasa and
you know everyone and it's there but
they don't really talk too much about it
and i believe that there's something
happened like
shortly after this discovery in his
house his house just got caught up in
house fire
that's crazy no way that's yeah look
into that it's my first time hearing it
too to be honest i'm gonna make a video
on that go for bro i'll send you
whatever resources i can find okay but
the man jack parsons i believe it was i
don't know if he was an astronaut or an
astrophysicist basically the man that
came out with the specific equation that
was necessary for all space technology
rockets and everything
this one thing by by name was mentioned
by him to come from the jaw
wow
that's that's crazy and you hear that uh
a lot in people who
take dmt in ayahuasca and and who's on
that bro he was on all that too oh was
he really yeah and that's crazy we've
made we've made a whole series called
the gin series 2 which you might you
might find particularly interesting and
we we talk about um a lot of
commonalities between anecdotal reports
when people say i've had alien
abductions right i've had alien
encounters other people say i've seen uh
dmt entities right
so we find a lot of commonalities
between the exact same words being
mentioned the exact same shapes and
objects being seen
as jin and the things that jin do and
the things that jin take forms and
shapes of so there's too many
commonalities between these two we bring
a lot of uh you know peer-reviewed
primary scientific literature into that
too so if you want to look at that
series you know feel free to look at
that but we talked about flow abductions
ufo sightings um you know alien
sightings and you know all these things
being in dmt entities
they're all gin bro and and we make it
very clear in that too so you know check
that out if you want i i definitely will
yeah if you could send me the link to it
it'd be easier
yeah got a lot of episodes i'll send you
like a link of all the videos we talked
about and then if you want to watch as
much of them as you want before we talk
the next time cool i will man we can
make like 10 episodes these honestly uh
yeah definitely
definitely um i just want to mention
some of the or uh respond to some of the
things that you mentioned uh about
humanity being so uh
kind of i would say progressed um
technologically and all of that but god
had to destroy them because of the what
we call what we would call fahisha and
fitna the tribulations and the the wrong
doing essentially that they were
committing so
you know thinking about it i can't find
anything islamically that would go
against that but in terms of mankind
knowing certain things from i would say
non-human
sources uh like jin and so on and so
forth it's explicitly mentioned that
first and foremost that shaitaan
actually created
musical instruments
to get the people to start dancing and
behaving in a certain way and to be more
intimate and all that to spread that
corruption so we believe that shaitaan
made instruments or satan made
instruments for mankind we believe that
god actually taught certain prophets
certain things so for example i believe
it was a prophet
idris
that he taught to like to to read and
write we know that he taught adam the
names of all things and so on and so
forth he taught i believe one prophet
how to make armor and all of that so
that would be black blacksmithing and as
well and all of that wow yeah and we
believe that the prophet solomon as i
had mentioned uh he was he actually was
given you know how he was given domain
over like the kingdoms like the animals
and all of that we believe he was also
given domain over the jinn kingdom
and that he essentially had them do
whatever he he wanted so
they had him construct i believe a
temple
uh and and so on and so forth so it's
it's possible i know i was looking at
certain things in like ancient
egypt and i know that they had like like
a battery
like an ancient bat yes yeah yeah you're
exactly right yeah that was crazy for me
to find out and to know that the
pyramids are constructed in a very
specific way uh is is amazing and it's
it's possible because some people say
that in the time of yusuf peace be upon
the prophet joseph that these pyramids
were actually used to hold the livestock
because if you don't know in the quran
it mentions um he had the king at the
time because they didn't have a pharaoh
at the time they had a king
this is before like pharaohs and all of
that
the king had a dream
that uh he saw i think seven skinny cows
eating eating seven fat cows and then
seven healthy grain uh like stock and
then seven unhealthy
oh sorry i'm getting a call right now
and then seven unhealthy grain uh stock
and all that so he called people to
interpret this dream and everything and
then at that point in time joseph was
actually locked in prison for something
he didn't do it was the whole story it's
actually called
the chapter is called joseph if you want
to listen to the recitation and read the
translation all that but it says that
the king the person who poured the wine
for the king he had his dream
interpreted by joseph when that the one
who poured the wine was also in prison
um and he remembered joseph at that time
he's like i know someone who can
interpret your dream for you because he
was a prophet of god he was given that
kind of wisdom so he went to the king
and he interpreted the dream saying
you're going to have seven years of
amazing provision of live
of um
basically stocking up on livelihood and
and food and grain and all that stuff
and then you have seven years of drought
so you need to save
basically a portion from the first seven
years for the next seven years and then
it was said that
um or i mean it's one opinion that these
pyramids and certain of the certain
structures were actually built to hold
the livestock for the seven years that
joseph was alive and the king and all of
that so it's very possible that these
were constructed in you know a
supernatural way i would say yeah well
regardless of what anybody thinks that
they
thinks that they know nobody knows what
the uh purpose of them was and you know
in school this this is the most
mind-blowing thing when i talk to people
and they think that the that the
mainstream narrative like it could
possibly be possibly be a lie i just
i'll just ask them i'll say uh i'll go
what do you think the pyramids were
built for and they'll go oh well they
were a tomb for the pharaoh and i'll go
i'll go there's never been a body found
in a pyramid ever and then and then
they're
what i what i was taught in school was
wrong yeah it was it was wrong nobody
has any idea that nobody even knows yeah
well nobody except god right that's why
in islam yeah yeah exactly it's saying
which means allah knows best
it's not it's not ignorance or us saying
oh we don't want to know but it's like
we could think we know but at the end
only allah knows best and allah knows
everything right um there's also other
things and then bro studying psychiatry
right now is one of my courses we're
studying about patients that have
multiple personality disorder or split
personality disorder right and basically
like when you look at this they they
feel possessed by by one alter that's
what they call it right basically when
when they feel like you know it takes
over um and then another day they have
another altar right so that's what
multiple personality disorder is and it
fully aligns with the sun because we
believe in multi-gen possessions as well
multiple gin can take you know take over
and possess you at the same time and
when you look at rookie or exorcism
videos online they literally talk to the
the people with the jinn in them while
they're they're extracting it and
they're casting them out and they
literally ask them like who are you and
some of them are believers like they're
muslim and some of them are atheist some
of them are men some of them are female
and when you look at multiple
personality disorder on a psychiatric
level all the alters aren't going to be
the same as you they might have a
different sex than you they may have a
different race than you right they might
have different religious and ideological
beliefs than you
so all we're trying to tell you is you
know we're not trying to sell islam to
anyone but me and rami us living our
life the reason we started this channel
was because everywhere we looked we
found islam it wasn't the other way
around and that's why we're very
passionate about that
the truth is self-evident for you yeah
100 yeah yeah 100
um i also want to mention now what the
stuff i mentioned about egypt it's not
an islamic opinion that the
um the pyramids were used for that
it's not at all i'm just saying yeah
yeah no i wasn't taking it like that oh
yeah yeah okay good yeah and i mean
that's another mystery that you know has
yet to be solved and all these things
are very very interesting
well and what you said about them having
a battery this is also really
interesting so i think there's there's a
lot of controversy over everything so
that's just a given with whatever we're
talking about especially the topics we
talk about um but what you said about
them having a battery um
there's also another thing you may not
know is that somehow they're able to
carbon date when they think that these
limestone rocks were cut and uh first
off they have no idea how they were cut
they say bronze swords and axes whatever
it's that's a lie
they've tried to do it it doesn't work
and
what's really interesting is that on the
ceilings of the pyramids you know people
would walk through with torches you know
during biblical times or you know during
the time of moses they'd walk through
torches and so they would burn the
bottom of of the stone okay well when
they go through and they carbonate the
um the soot from the from the fire of
the torches they never find soot that is
as old as when they think the pyramids
were cut so that's to say when the
pyramids were first built
it is speculated that people were not
walking and walking around inside the
pyramids using torches to navigate
so
you know how did they how did they have
light isn't that crazy yeah that's
insane
yeah so
yeah that's that's just another that's
just another
rabbit hole we can go down
by the way bro um and no no hard
feelings if you didn't but did you see
any of our videos particularly the
reaction video that we made to your
video yet or not yet i i watched half of
it and i listened to the whole thing uh
with christmas things kind of got crazy
because i was going home i listened to
the entire thing uh on the way home
okay because i was going to say that
there was a guest we had on that on that
episode um a sister um and she actually
studied you know called sciences and all
that way more so maybe one day we could
have a crossover and have you know oh
yeah yeah oh my gosh yeah she's she's an
encyclopedia yeah 100 he knows
everything and bro by the way um if you
do feel like you know um you know
where's the third muslim because we are
the three muslims uh brother angel he's
currently on the move he is uh he's
moving right now so because of that he
wasn't able to make it um but i think
this is approaching the end of this
episode i learned so much stuff bro and
it was great to see um exactly where you
are with your thinking and how you got
here and us sharing our experiences too
yeah
i really appreciate you guys putting me
out i'm sorry to cut you off i really
appreciate you guys bringing me on here
and uh reaching out to me and everything
it's really really flattering and uh
y'all are both
very nice really easy to talk to uh like
i said before i'm sure we could talk for
days over this kind of stuff
yeah for sure for sure and the honor is
all ours you know we do appreciate the
videos that you make so we it was
honestly our pleasure to have you on so
thank you for coming on well i hope i
hope we all keep growing and and this
thing just compounds and compounds you
know and uh and i wish nothing but
success for you guys
perfect bro um so we thank you for that
and for all of our viewers that want to
get more of your content more of your
work where can they find you bro
so it's just luke caverns on everything
if you look up luke caverns you'll be
able to find me if you really want to go
deep in uh more formal videos i make
pretty casual stuff on my luke caverns
channel but if you really want to go
deep into the actual history where i'm
not just joking around uh ancient
origins with luke caverns there's
another channel out there called ancient
origins and i didn't steal the name from
them i thought of it also and it was too
good not to use so it's just ancient
origins with loot caverns but uh you can
find me like on tick tock instagram
whatever just luke caverns and on
snapchat if you're interested in that
perfect so i'm gonna link everything in
the description box below make sure you
guys smash the like button if you made
it this far comment down below hashtag
luke and stay tuned for more videos with
you in the future
awesome hey thank you guys so much
of course it was our pleasure and with
that being said allahumma at dunya
s
all right luke until next time hey man
good really really good to talk to you
guys thank you i think there's another
thing too it's it's the perseverance
aspect too
like we're more willing to stick through
with things that we set out with an
intention it's impossible to have
empathy for others if you're not patient
so my love bless you for that first of
all i agree with the fact that
the whole thing you said about friends
where it's like if they're affecting you
more than you're affecting them then you
should probably get some new friends
you want to be investing stocks shares
bonds you want to be investing in crypto
because there's this thing called
inflation which means every year that
passes by
the value of a dollar goes lower and
lower and lower and the reason being is
because they're printing more money
right that's why money is haram at least
the paper money is haram provided that
you're actually there and you're being a
good father and the mother's being a
good mother best conditions and behind
the mic hamza andreas zorces we will go
in with our final three with brother
angel
it's not just a responsibility on you
it's responsibility on all the children
especially your father in our private
area is very elastic and yeah if you go
too fast the skin will literally crease
up into like the edge
of like the little clipper things and
you will literally clip your skin you
don't want to be on youtube or the
internet or anything
that that amount of time but it's it's
the the fact is that's what we're doing
um
um
[Music]